Blue Bloods fans were stunned earlier
this fall and the show and ceremoniously
killed off one of its main characters
especially since the actress had touted
the show just two months before every
bit as it turns out the cast was reeling
just as much as everyone else the show's
actors recently spoke out on the
departure of Amy Carlson who's Linda
Reagan was revealed to be dead in the
season 8 premiere revealing their shock
and disappointment with the characters
abrupt demise Linda died off screen with
the show revealing in its return that a
character had been killed in a
helicopter crash two months earlier
after her exit Colson wrote a note of
thanks for fans who had supported her
throughout the series although she said
she was grateful to the cast and crew
deadline reports that there may have
been some trouble behind the scenes with
Colson reportedly deciding it was quote
time to move on after fulfilling her
contract while Linda's death was hard on
fans it was also especially hard on the
character's husband Danny played by
Donnie Wahlberg Wahlberg said he didn't
have to stray far from the truth to play
the grieving widower he told the crowd
at PaleyFest in New York rather than
tried to act or find something to do I
just thought about my friend Amy Carlson
I thought about all the years together
and all the highs and lows and the ups
and downs on the journey any tears I
shed in that scene was really Donnie
shedding them for Amy hopefully his
family of our cast the show and the
viewers will all mourn the loss together
and move forward after the season some
of Wahlberg's other co-stars also
expressed their sadness a Coulson's
decision to leave the show Sammy Gale
told TV Line Amy made the decision to
leave but we adore her we're very sad
she left Marisa Ramirez who plays
Danny's partner Detective Maria Baez
thinks the departure will prove
interesting for the show because Danny
will now need to turn to her support
adding we'll see if he takes it because
he's very very stubborn meanwhile her
co-star Bridget Moynahan added that she
was disappointed to learn that the
actress was departing saying it was
unfortunate that she made that decision
at the end of season seven so we were
stuck with the storyline as we could get
it but I'm really thrilled for her to go
off and pursue other things and follow
what she felt was best for her Carlson
for her parts wrote on Twitter that she
was appalled and sad about the comments
made at PaleyFest saying I love the show
cast and playing her why are y'all
looking at me thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]